i think then when i first got my
my hands around a budweiser bottle
and i felt that sweet sweet
elixir hit my lips and i was like oh
i
feel like kind of normal and then it was
like what else could make me feel normal
and then it was just the quest you know
wow
i mean so so at an early age you were
already getting these suicidal thoughts
you already knew something was not quite
right and your parents didn't know how
to help you so it just kind of uh you
went into a tailspin i guess eventually
right yeah and they couldn't control it
i was
i was what you call high functioning in
the sense that like i was definitely uh
scholastically you know above average
throughout high school i participated in
uh extracurricular activities i i loved
theater in the arts i also loved sport
and i loved um
having a good time obviously but you
know i was um
it was a dangerous concoction because i
was very good at i mean
i was a good actor i was good at
pretending like you know i was
i was okay
how did you get off it how what was the
final because you used to have to hit i
guess you have to hit rock bottom before
something happens right and they're
homeless i was homeless um
anybody who is checking out this
conversation and and you know wants to i
i wrote and acted
in a film that my dear friend colin
animals called animals yes and if you
guys ever get a chance to check it out
it's not my bio pic but it is definitely
inspired by the reality and in the film
you know a guy and his girlfriend live
in their car and i did i lived in a car
for quite a while i was stealing um
anything i could to resell to support my
habit i was
um
i it was it was terrible man i was um
thoroughly ashamed of myself as soon as
i would start to get sick or come down
and withdrawal the shame and the guilt
of what i had done with my life and all
this opportunity having been a
privileged white kid from kansas city
who had gotten to go study acting at
this amazing school was
spending his
throwing his life away on like smack i
was like i was so ashamed and so
embarrassed and i
the voices that were like
you're no good to the world
you're no good to anybody who loves you
because all you do is continue to bring
them misery and suffering
why why don't you do
everybody
one solid in your life like finally do
that one solid
and actually think about everyone but
yourself for a minute and just be done
and just end it
and so um i made the most serious i made
several i mean i've made several
attempts in my life but the most serious
attempt which i came
you know as close as you probably can
come
to
committing suicide and by a miracle
nothing short of a miracle i survived i
was put into a
state psychiatric facility in illinois i
there
was able to spend 30 days without drugs
because i was kind of strapped to a cot
and then
as i came out of that i
had learned some basic tools and i had
gotten a taste of
recovery and the potential of what was
there and my family was right there to
say we love you we're here to support
you and i realized that
all that illusion that my brain had been
you know tricking me into was um was
just that an illusion and that i was
going to
use these tools that i had started to
learn um and i [ __ ] up
numerous it took me a whole other
year from that point to continue to
relapse continue to disappoint myself
and others continue to like
screw up but i i got there man and um i
spent a num uh like three or four years
in chicago just
working a day job and
smoking cigarettes and writing and i
never thought i would get to act again i
never thought i would get to um you know
be creative in a professional sense but
i definitely was grateful because i had
a futon and a tv and a cat and um
and then sure [ __ ] some friends of mine
from the old theater days saw me working
in the movie theater where i was working
at nights and were like you gotta be
we're doing this oscar wilde player
we're doing i'm starting a theater
company and
they kind of pulled me
lovingly
back to where i belonged